avec ce qu'a écrit benjamin castaldi sur
son grand père je veux dire en disant
que c'était un obsédé sexuel dans le
déni quand il s'est fait jésus les
cartes dans quoi il sert l'écrivain
s'est pareillement quoi dans l'autorail
quelques lignes dans le ligue américaine
kelly nké page quelle phrase quelle page
web c'était un obsédé sexuel ce type
était un véritable site oui j'ai dit
j'ai kiffé avoir dansé moi le truc me il
faudra c'est à dire bien sûr mais mais
bien sûr c'était quand on perd chez ge
olivia ça il ya plein d'autres choses
aussi
et qu'est ce que je voulais dire s'il
vous plaît à
voila voila vous qui la voient là après
tout ce qui s'est fait taper dessus
benjamin par toute la presse parce qu'il
a eu le courage de dire certaines choses
et maintenant il essaye un peu de se
rattraper tout mais la vérité est ce
qu'elle est bien la vérité moi j'ai rien
contre lui j'aime bien ça se voit
benjamin vous vous étiez parler avant
que le livre sorte on s'est parlé mais
quand j'ai découvert qu'il voulait faire
en fait un livre à charge et d'ailleurs
non non pas du tout qui est qui écrit à
charge d'ailleurs une minime une
citation au début oui mais où mais qu'il
est il n'est pas un biographe qui trompe
sa plume dans la guimauve oui mais voilà
ces votes c'est que vous avez trompés
dans la mer les gosses et
si c'est si facile écrit ça donc
je vous le dis les grands jamais
suffisant et que la merde il pue la
merde et
puis la merde
[Musique]
à ses qualités c'est un homme points et
adam avait écrit des choses moi je n'ai
rien mais je deviens maire a écrit un
livre écorné la part de ma mère et j'ai
laissé le relais et carole amiel c'est
bon c'est mon passe temps mais ça suffit
oui madame amon bâtiment mais chez moi
je vous dis une chose montant il est
mort il ya trente ans aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui voilà je trouve ça inutile
il s'était certainement comme beaucoup
de gens connus avec des avec des zones
dont moi je trouve que trente ans et ça
n'a pas grand intérêt ça n'a pas grand
intérêt moi j'essaie depuis quelques
années de réhabiliter et à la fois ma
grand-mère et la fois mon temps et vous
dit des horreurs sur ma grand mère je
leur ai même pas dessus parce que ça ça
va nous marquer ce qu'il n'y avait pas
moi et non géré mais ça me donne envie
de gerber de cherves et dit vouloir sa
grand mère c'est même pas la peine de
répéter
moi
j'ai interrogé des gens qui ont connu le
dire je tape bien cirées donc c'est un
livre d'histoire jeu c'est une histoire
rien et du montant c'est un personnage
public les gens ont mis bien sûr je le
les gens l'aiment après avoir lu cela
oui abbas est permis bonjour je fais une
biographie sur vous avancer de nouveau
vous allez voir le verre à yves très
très sympa sociale j'aimerais qu'on
vienne thiam assuré christian pellet
vivre moi j'écris monsieur p emmanuel
emmanuel j'ai pas de [ __ ] je fais moi
même mais moi mais bois provenant je les
dédie j'avais créé ouvrait la voie de
matsot tu ne commences à me faire chier
je te le dis théo d'y cacher des normes
ghazaouet vase et est énorme réservoir
des neuf heures contre gamme bouffon tu
as tu as entre eux tu as moi j'ai débuté
chez chez bernard pivot mon premier vous
bailly dans ses pages à tapas et
critiques chez lui chez michel drucker
pour edith piaf ou quatre coeurs connais
mes qualités j'ai lu leur téléphone et
il m'a fait des confidences que je
répèterai pas ici
non